Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September 30th,
2013 what's going on?
How are Ya?
How's it going?
Did you have a nice weekend?
I had a great weekend.
Do you like when somebody does that to you where they act like they want to know
what your weekends like so they can just talk about their bullshit,
you know?
Did you guys have a nice weekend?
I did.
Well,
let me tell you all the awesome fucking Shit I did.
Hang on,
let me get my juice.
I got to get my juice Sovi here so I stay regular.
Ow.
Fuck God dammit.
You gotta be shitting me.
I just spilled it all over my fucking drunk kit.
What an asshole.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Well,
you know what?
I had a great weekend.
Fucking weeks not starting off by the time this podcast is over.
This is quite,
it's gonna be all sticky.
Really?
Did it really have to fucking land there?
Juice gods?
I just dumped it over again trying to set it down the fucking rug.
All right,
hang on.
I got to hit pause here,
son of a buck.
All right.
I'm back.
And Jesus Christ that once but twice.
You know what an asshole don't Jake,
doesn't it the fucking worst?
Just owning shit.
I bet.
When you didn't own anything,
if you're young right now,
you don't own something.
You fucking spill some.
You don't give a shit.
Eh,
I'll get it later.
I said I'll get it later now.
I've got to be all concerned.
It's fucking hilarious.
Just see this stuff on drinking spilled on the rug.
Looks like God damn.
Extra sisters like nothing left.
Crisis was gonna be my breakfast.
Um,
yeah,
it was in Chicago this weekend,
right?
So I ate like a pig because that's what you do there.
You eat like a fucking pig and you grow a mustache even though nobody has a
mustache out there that I saw.
Um,
and they weren't really fat either,
but I got to work at the,
uh,
the beautiful,
Chicago theater did two shows out there and um,
I'm not going to lie to you.
It was a little overwhelming.
That was,
uh,
I got to tell you,
it's like Royal Albert Hall is something that I would try and compare it to.
I took a tour that one time when I was out there in London for you,
led Zeppelin fans,
fans of led Zeppelin.
If you wear a watch that,
oh that,
that fucking video too,
which to me is a new one,
but had already came out 10 years ago,
um,
that has all their concert footage up one from 1970.
That's where that is filmed.
Royal Albert Hall.
And as far as the states go,
the closest thing that we have to that would be the Chicago theater.
And I got to perform in it and it was pretty awesome.
And that's the end of that story.
I'm still fucking pissed about this.
It was a great time.
So I want to thank everybody for coming out there and you know what sucks is I
was so fucking overwhelmed,
I forgot I was going to sing when I came out there.
You know how it's going to come out and be like,
now kid only happen to a guy like baby booboo.
And only happened and uh,
so let me say too,
we told you,
um,
I could have done that,
could add a great fucking time and I forgot because I was too busy going like,
hey man,
I gotta make sure I do a good job here man.
This is like one of these big ones.
Um,
so anyways,
you probably asked yourself,
hey bill,
other than the usual feminine aspects of your personality,
why is it that you're drinking juice
breakfast?
Why is it um,
uh,
I dunno why.
Cause I eat like shit this weekend and then,
uh,
I dunno,
I ate something last week that my,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
My body treated it like a,
a terrorist cell.
It was like,
well,
you need to get these fuckers out of this country immediately
and we don't care how many innocent people we have to take with it.
All right,
there's going to be some collateral damage here.
Okay.
Everything in this sector has to go,
but we did that.
I said,
get Outta here.
All right.
For like four hours last week.
And it was such an effective,
like my body will basically committed genocide on my,
my large intestine,
there was nothing left.
Okay.
So like three to the point,
like three days later,
I don't want to get all graphic here three days later,
you know,
they'll basically,
other than I'll try to say this as nicely as possible,
other than watching a game that was real or if I was tired,
there was no reason,
full red face here to have to sit down,
if you know what I mean.
But like three straight days.
So now I think like,
well wait a minute.
So what happened?
So now if I got gotten the other way at our,
my end,
uh,
you know,
I went from fucking what wide open to to,
it's like a Justin,
a carburetor was too rich and now now and might get nothing.
I got the choke pulled all the way out here.
Is that,
what the fuck's going on here?
I got no way down there.
So I'm freaking out and I'm like,
I've been fucking eating salads trying to,
you know,
so,
uh,
I talked to this doctor and he goes,
and the guy just broke the thing down.
He goes,
all right,
so what happened?
I was like,
well,
you know,
four days ago,
it's so funny when you have to call a doctor about that.
Like,
how do you eloquently say like,
yeah,
listen,
man,
I haven't like shit.
And four days,
is that a,
is that a bad thing?
And they just handle it like a chair.
All right,
well,
what happened five days ago?
I was shitting my brains out for like four hours.
You know,
it was like the,
uh,
the DOTCOM boom,
and everybody thought it was gonna last forever and it just,
it,
the bubble burst.
Now it's nothing.
So he's like,
well,
you haven't any abdominal pain.
Uh,
the are running a fever.
I'm like,
nope,
nope.
Well,
he goes,
wait a minute.
And I've go,
I've been eating salads,
and it goes,
all right,
well,
you probably don't want to do that.
You don't need any more roughage.
You want something else?
And he said,
you need,
he actually said,
Syrup said,
go out,
get yourself some pancakes.
I'll go have a waffle or something like that.
Elicit,
you don't need to fuck it.
Tell me more than one time to go out and get some fucking pancakes.
All right.
With my sweet tooth.
Okay.
I'm a little light in the loafers over here when it comes to food.
I don't mind a little sugar in my tank.
I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
So I'm in Chicago,
so I go out and I go to get,
I need,
I need some syrup.
All right?
So I can't go down to the front desk and say,
hey listen,
I need some syrup because,
uh,
you know,
the old Bose not playing any music anymore,
if you know what I mean here.
And um,
you know,
if that even made sense,
I would have,
I'm running out of metaphors here,
not saying I'm having shit.
So I don't know.
I just asked that content,
my phone where the nearest diner is.
She's like,
I found 47 locations and then just,
you know,
carpet bombs,
the screen.
So I pick one that's like about 0.3 miles away and I will go in there,
go and maybe I'll just go in there and get a shot of syrup with an orange juice
chaser.
And I said,
no,
fuck it.
I'll get,
I'll get some French toast.
So anyways,
I'm down near the Chicago theater and there's this weird part of the city where
there's like a city underneath the city.
I don't get it.
So I'm walking over towards it and you know the phone isn't three dimensional,
so it's saying right there,
but it's actually one level down.
It almost looked like a blade runner.
So I'm sitting there of course cursing up a storm around children and families
of course comes fucking stupid ass fucking phone number.
Back in the fucking day you just ask somebody where the fuck's the diner and
they'd be like,
oh it's Dan,
but it's downstairs so you've got to walk down here.
Okay,
let's suppose this can't just go,
oh it's right over here.
Nickeled left do this.
Yeah,
you off.
Siri doesn't care.
The surgery,
whatever.
Fucking,
he's just give a shit.
If you fall,
if rappelling is involved,
she doesn't give a fuck.
All right,
well that's not her fault.
She's only as smart as the man that made her.
Um,
so anyways,
I find the stairs,
I'm flipping out,
of course there's stairs.
I go down the goddamn stairs.
So I walk in and I,
uh,
I dunno.
I,
I ordered some French toast
and you would thank,
you know,
it will be the size.
The French toast would be the size of a sandwich bread like it is in most
places.
But this is the Midwest particularly I say that might particularly,
uh,
Chicago and I swear to God,
the French toast shows up and it looks like,
you know,
it'd be like,
if they decided how big should that the French toasts be,
and it'd be like,
hey,
does anybody have one,
a Bubba's Smith's old fucking clique's?
Let's just stick that in the batter and trace it.
And that'll be a how big the fucking bread should be.
Can you trace shit and batter?
I guess you can't have stick enough.
Oh yeah.
Well,
let's trace the Brett around.
I'm just saying it was fucking huge.
And then they gave me two slices,
his left and right foot with powdered sugar.
And I ordered an egg over easy on the side,
cause I like eggs.
And I got to tell you something,
man.
I went to his place called Eggy all terrible fucking name.
Hey,
let's go over to fucking eggy.
It.
Doesn't that sound like they're going to be runny.
I got to tell you,
the greatest egg over easy I ever had in my life.
The Yolk was eg.
Hey,
take it age.
They get AIG.
The egg,
the Yolk was fucking easy.
But the,
the white part of the egg was,
um,
the Areola of the egg was fucking solid.
I don't know how they did it.
I was like,
maybe it had the heat real high,
so bright before the fucking yoke.
It's solid.
The white park,
it's all hard had.
And then they slip it out.
I have no idea.
But it was fucking delicious.
And I'm one of those guys,
I need a piece of toast if I'm going to have an egg and I didn't have toast and
it was still delicious,
still delicious.
And then I ate one of the French toast.
Thanks.
And I left the other cleat to the French toast hall of fame.
All right.
And wasn't,
should know what you know,
three hours later.
Okay,
well Billy was making music out the other end again.
And that's the end of my giant shit story.
All right?
This is the Monday morning podcast,
everybody.
So there's one for you.
If you have any shit your fucking brains out,
and then you know,
and you're still eating well the next few days and you haven't gone,
go get yourself a shot.
A syrup with an orange juice chaser.
All right?
And you're going to be right as rain.
Okay.
Now granted,
after four days,
roadkill is coming out of here it is.
It's disgusting.
Um,
I let me get a shot at UCL.
That's a good stuff.
MMM.
So anyways,
what else?
What else do I want to talk about?
Oh,
last night.
Hey,
breaking bad is over.
I want to be in the nine millions person to talk about it.
But Jesus Christ wasn't a great ending.
I loved it.
I thought they uh,
I thought they stuck the landing.
I'm not going to ruin for everybody cause they're east.
What?
Lowly yard cc too.
It's been out for six years.
Jesus,
I don't know.
You know what?
I've never watched an episode of lost.
Have you seen lost now?
I haven't.
Every time I put it on it's that guy with the giant head in the Paula Malo
haircut and I can't figure out what the fuck's going on.
And then the captain from Star Trek is being evil.
That's all I know that goes on on that show.
So I have empathy so I'm not going to say anything but um,
it was great.
It was a great fucking time getting to be on that show and a half.
Fuck.
I mean there's no way to talk about it unless somebody saw the shelf.
Why the hell they bring it up anyways,
so there you go.
The show's over and I am unemployed as an actor again.
And that is why that is why you well know.
That's why I would never stop doing stand up even if I didn't love it is because
trying to be a working actor is that difficult that you can be on something that
great and then it just fucking ends and it's over like stand up.
That doesn't happen.
Like if,
if I was doing standup at the level of breaking bad,
that wouldn't be like,
okay and this is your final standup Gig and then it drops off again.
I go right down to ground zero and have to look for more standup gigs and like
prove myself all over again.
I've often wondered like try it.
What's the hardest either it's either trying to make it as far as show business,
either trying to make it as an actor or trying to make it in a band bands a
rough one because you've got to split the money at least three ways,
you know,
unless you're in the uh,
the black keys or if you're in the white stripes,
then you split it two ways.
But still you got to get along with somebody else.
All right?
And the more people you have and you've banned the biggest chance that it's just
all going to go to shit.
Look at guns and roses.
All right?
They had five people in the band.
They start fighting.
So a couple of guys leave,
one guy gets asked to leave,
another guy says,
hey,
I don't like being dictated to.
So he takes off.
No Steven,
no Izzy.
So they bring in fucking Matt Sorum and Gilby cluck.
Right?
So you got five guys and what do they do when they bring in a keyboard is dizzy.
They got in horn players.
All it is is more people to be late to come downstairs to get on the fucking bus
and the whole thing implodes.
Everybody goes their separate ways.
Right?
And next thing you know,
axle has cornrows.
Okay?
Now had that guy decided to just tell jokes just to do stand up,
you know,
which would've been great.
When would be great to see some actual doing stand up.
Every time he tells a joke that gets an applause break.
He does it a little surf at dance to decide.
I'm really trying to think of a joke that ends with Shannon.
You know where he could fucking,
I dunno.
Um,
let me pay nice sketch.
Axl Rose is a stent.
If he proposes a stand up comedian,
he come on late.
He'd probably still fuck it up not to have a little red on red crime here.
All right.
Okay.
You got to hate when people do that.
Yeah,
you got to hate one.
It becomes cannibalism here.
I just completely lost my train of thought.
Oh,
I know what I was going to say.
Wait a minute.
How far into the salary?
About 15 minutes in it's time to do a couple of reads here,
people.
All right.
It's time to time to whore myself out.
All right,
let's do a couple here.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
There was so many things in the world that irritate me.
Spilling juice on my kit.
I don't have a drum
kit.
It's a little practice pad thing,
but I got,
I do have the DW 5,000 double kick there.
Right?
When I finally got fed up 10 years ago that I was never going to have a foot
fast,
fastest John Bonham.
And he said to hell with it,
let me try to do this speed metal stuff.
And that was just as hard,
right?
So now I got this double pedal and it's just sitting there like you remember
those hair metal bands in the 80s,
whether they'd be just play in to four basic Phil Rudd stuff,
but they still did double bass drum kit.
So when they did the,
uh,
the drum solo,
that could just be running underneath it and sound like,
you know,
Neil Pure,
whenever the fuck,
when did,
when did they become part?
You're pure it.
Neil peered,
I don't know where it was.
Neil Park,
the whole,
his whole fucking career.
Not,
I know,
that irritates me and it's not Neil part anymore.
It's near peer.
Um,
so those are the things that irritate me.
Pay.
But when so many things can irritate you,
why ed raises to the list,
you know,
it's time to stop milking your razor blades.
People I know with brand name razors,
you used to paying outrageous prices and exhausting those razors and until they
start looking like a rusty soda kid,
well guess what?
It's time to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month.
Never think about it again.
All right.
You just stand in that bank bong.
They should blades for a month.
They send you a pack every month so you can change your blades every week.
That's awesome man.
That's one of,
why didn't I think of doing this.
I went up to jump around like a monkey on stage every damn week.
Anyways,
I love these guys and your face is going to love them too.
They also got a new product called one wipe Charlies.
It's about white for men and it's classic.
All right.
As opposed to that low class toilet play paper,
just hanging around,
you know,
one wipe Charlie,
get in and get out.
All right,
the Harvey Keitel,
the cleaner if you will,
of toilet paper and it,
okay.
Check out the video for that.
Sign up for your razors today.
Go to dollar shave club.com,
forward slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com,
forward slash for Ortho to billboard.com and Click on the dollar shave club
banner.
I almost made it through it.
Um,
you know what a one wipe Charlie is?
That's basically America's slowly admitting that the French got it right with
the bad day.
Okay?
What we're doing over here with toilet paper is ridiculous.
I'm telling you,
if you ever get into a hotel and there's a,
there's a big day,
um,
make yourself take the dozen books,
just a big shit podcast.
I'm telling you,
you got to use one and you'll be like,
what the hell have I been doing?
You know,
with my life,
although I'd maintained that French people are still more sticky than we are
because they don't use deodorant and who's getting hurt when you have a question
in class,
you don't spread your ass cheek.
All right?
I think everyone can agree.
You raise your arm.
All right?
All right.
Who will plus everybody?
You've probably tried Hulu Dot.
Now with
Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus let you watch thousands,
a hit TV shows and a selection of a claim,
movies on your television or on the go with your smartphone or tablet and it
streams all of this stuff in HD for the best viewing experience possible with
Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live
community,
family guy.
Uh,
what else?
Breaking bad.
You can get all caught up.
You could probably watch lost if you want it to.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals,
like the awesomes,
starring Snl,
Seth Meyers and moon boy starring Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids who the plus all
also offers a great selection of a claim films for only seven 99 a month.
You can't beat that.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want wherever you want right
now.
You can try Hulu plus free for two weeks when you go to Hulu plus.com/bill
that's a special offer for my listeners.
I love that line.
For my listeners,
not yours.
Mine.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you get the extended free trial and a
then they'll know that we sent you and they'll realize that this is working.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page
at [inaudible] Dot Com ah,
right now,
wasn't that nice?
Wasn't that Nice and painless?
All right.
Here's what a cunt I am and we learned last week that I'm a real cunt.
All right,
I'm the real deal.
And if you tip me over,
you're going to see the current stamp of approval right on my left butt cheek.
Cause I'm a lefty sort of.
I'm also a writer.
I'm all over the map.
God Damn it.
This fucking juice.
It's delicious.
Kale,
celery,
green,
apple,
coriander.
The fuck is that Parsley in line?
What the Hell is coriander?
I can't be a spice.
Can't get any juice out of a spice.
That's the Dandruff or food spices,
right?
Anybody have a dandruff and an Omelet,
you know,
prisoner of war.
Like,
Oh,
it's disgusting.
Um lets
you use dandruff is powdered sugar as you put it on like a wood shingle,
pretending it was French toast.
That's like just some greatest generation shit.
And they did it and then they never talked about it and then subconsciously took
it out on their kids.
Um,
and then you've got the baby boom generation,
bunch of fucking cry babies.
Oh my God.
Was there ever a bigger pussy generation than them?
We don't want to go to war.
I just making up shit.
People don't take this seriously.
Oh you can,
but I don't give a fuck.
Uh,
oh.
So let's talk about what a cunt I am.
I'm driving down to get my juice today,
my medicine and um,
you know,
someone was texting me and all this type of shit.
Okay.
And I'm trying not to text while I drive,
but do my text him back like I can't tell you podcast today.
I'll do it next week doing Kevin Farley's podcast next week,
yet another person on the all things comedy network.
Um,
so by the way,
I'll be on that next week.
So anyways,
I'm driving over to the juice bar and I pull in,
I get the juice,
throw the bag,
come back out and there's like nobody there.
I got a great parking spot and all I want to do is just whip around,
do a u turn right.
Like I'm Adam 12 every time they got a call,
they will never go in the right direction.
They always had turnaround.
Right.
And you just can't,
it's like a fucking out here in la.
I swear to God.
It's like the God Damn Truman show and says,
just know what the fuck you going to do.
So I go to do it and out of nowhere,
this fucking jerk off.
He just appears right.
Right out of the fucking air.
And not only does he blocked me from doing it,
like I'm just starting to pull out a little bit.
He's pulls into the parking spot right in front of me,
front end first and almost takes off my front end.
Yeah,
he didn't like when you almost get into an accident even when you're wrong,
cause I was wrong.
I should've looked,
he had the right away.
But you get mad.
Like I flipped out.
I just,
cause I got scared like,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna rip off the front of my car.
And then it didn't happen.
I was like,
Oh,
you start flipping out then and as you yelling at the guy inside your car,
there's that voice in the back of your head going,
you were wrong.
You were the wrong one.
That happened like three times,
just fucking jerk off in front of me.
I'd go around the block and he's doing that,
driving what?
You know that texting,
you know,
sort of creeping along and then,
and then all of a sudden I know we're going real fast.
All of a sudden they're a good drive and then they completely suck at driving.
Then there it's like they're sober,
they're drunk,
they're sober,
that drunk.
That is fucking classic texting while driving.
And I pull up alongside of the guy,
look at him.
Sure enough,
he's looking down as he's driving and I'm going to go look at this fucking idiot
texted while driving.
Okay.
And literally I had been doing it a half mile earlier,
probably making the same person do that.
I'm such a fucking hypocritical cont,
you know,
at least I guess maybe I can hear it.
Who the hell is texting me?
Jesus Christ,
these people.
No,
I still choose all of my rug and I don't have time for texts.
MMM.
Anyways,
so,
uh,
I don't even know if I even said it.
I want to thank everybody who came out to,
uh,
the Chicago theater this weekend,
that that was an unbelievable,
unbelievable experience and I definitely took a lot of photos,
took a lot of video because that's one of those things where you're doing it and
you're like,
am I ever going to get to do this again?
It was insane.
Um,
and if you ever get a chance to go to Chicago,
here's a great,
there's a great little weekend trip for those of you who don't live there.
And Chicago is basically,
I know it's a little more east coast,
but essentially it's,
it's no more than a four hour flight for in the lower 48 here.
Um,
if you favorite band is playing there,
that would be a great weekend going there.
See your favorite band at the Chicago theater and then hang out and eat.
They're awesome heart attack food.
Uh,
which I didn't even get a chance to do because of,
uh,
the earlier story and also I flew in that day.
Oh,
you know what the fuck I should have taken the weekend there,
but I'm too busy.
I'm going right back up this weekend.
The El Paso Gig people is happening trying to happen again for the third fucking
time.
I've already lost two fans for life because of this Gig.
But I am determined.
I am determined that I'm going to make this thing happen.
And uh,
the Gig is on Wednesday and uh,
last time it was going to be Paul Versey who is going to open for me.
Uh,
he's busy this time around,
um,
bringing,
uh,
the Rosebowl tailgate king.
All right.
The Sinatra of our rose bolt tailgate.
Uh,
Joe Barton.
Nick is coming out and uh,
this guy is one of my favorite people and one of the funniest people I've ever
met in my life.
He's funny when he's trying to be funny and he's funny even when he's not trying
to be funny.
He's a total fucking original.
Really just lives by his own code is just a,
it's fucking awesome man.
He's a throwback throwback to a different era.
Um,
so he's going to be coming out there.
I'm actually,
believe it or not,
I'm going to drive out there.
That's how beautiful the drive from El Paso to San Antonio was.
I got to see the rest of this.
I got to see the rest of the south west side driving La to El Paso.
It's like a 12 hour drive,
which that's not,
that's not bad.
You know,
he just break it up,
break it up.
But I'm,
I'm timing it where I'm going to be out in the desert as the sun's going down.
Uh,
look at me drinking juice,
trying to see,
is that right?
Am I evolving as a man or am I a,
am I going to start going on stage like Duran Duran wearing a little bit of
makeup?
That wouldn't be bad,
right.
A little eyeliner.
What'd you guys do if I went that direction at all my,
all my,
I stopped talking about it's about sports.
I went that direction and then all of a sudden everybody was saying that I was
ripping off.
Eddie Izzard
is a left turn,
you know,
or Bryan Adams after,
he came out and he was wearing a jean jacket looking like the guy that might
have some weed and then all of a sudden he decided I can't,
you know,
he became more poppy.
Everything you'd do.
I,
everything I do,
I do it for you.
That's one of the saddest fucking songs ever.
Just completely lost in a relationship.
You've completely,
you know,
you know his friends.
Hey,
should we call a Bryant?
Nah.
You know,
once you have it sets,
he met Julie.
You know,
Jeez is fine.
Never thought it would happen to him.
Remember that we used to fucking,
you know,
you should get fucked up in the barn,
right?
Whatever the fuck they did in that video.
And then somewhere along the line he spiked up his hair and put on some
eyeliner,
Jesus Christ.
You know,
when he was making that video,
he was just saying to his manager,
like,
dude,
this is either the beginning or the end,
uh,
this better fucking work in the manager's probably be like,
Nah,
I said,
great thing.
It's a great fucking thing.
And then when it's shit,
the bed manager can't be found,
where the hell is he?
All right,
let's talk NFL football.
Uh,
unfortunately I didn't really see any this week.
I,
I was flying back from,
uh,
Chicago when all the early games were on and then,
um,
my patriots will late night and I ain't even get a chance to see that because
this is what I did.
I came home and I got caught up on the scores just in time.
I haven't really seen the highlights to see Seattle's big comeback or the Texans
big choke depending on what side of the ball you're on.
Um,
I know the jets lost.
Uh,
all I saw was the first quarter and a half of the Patriots.
And,
um,
I'm happy that we were able to get past the falcons cause I feel like that's the
first quality team that we've played.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I already saw somebody was trying to say that we're the only ones going to
legitimately challenged the Broncos and I don't think it's going to be much,
I don't know.
You never know when Belichick is involved,
what scheme he can come up with and God knows you can frustrate Peyton manning
but they look fucking amazing.
So,
uh,
I wish that the Broncos would just play Seattle already cause I want to see,
you know,
two things.
I want to see Seattle on the road against the team,
that good cause versus has been telling me they're not good on the road.
He almost called it with the Texans.
They didn't fucking choke.
Um,
I saw the picture on nfl.com.
It's hilarious.
Is a Sherman the beasts,
they're running the ball back and you get to see,
you get to see Pete Carroll.
Pete Carol is in full,
like I can't tell if you just finished going woo or if he's about ready to say
it.
Uh,
but they,
uh,
they look and like fucking world beaters up there.
I got,
oh by the way,
I'm going to be up in Seattle this week and uh,
this is going to be fucking hilarious cause it's,
I'm playing this awesome venue plus all the morning radio shows up there.
I think for the most part they,
they played when I was singing.
We are the loudest,
so there's a lot of pissed off.
Um,
12th man people out there.
So I dunno.
We're going to see.
We'll see.
What the fuck happens.
I don't give a shit either way to be honest with you.
Um,
if something goes down when I'm up there,
that's,
it's a very easy city to make fun of.
So I think I can do more than 12 minutes.
Um,
but I,
I'm hoping it's not going to be,
you know,
what is annoying about all those morning radio shows is all they did was like,
now they'll just right there,
they won't have this part.
They left out the whole part where I said I thought that Seattle was going to go
to the Superbowl and they looked like the team to beat.
Um,
they lift that they left out where I,
you know,
didn't give Pete Carroll Shit for what the fuck he did at USC because everybody
does it.
By the way,
people are still doing that spy gate shit bringing up,
uh,
you know,
bringing up Bella check and that type of thing.
Like they always love to do with the Patriots.
I was watching the Lsu game.
Unfortunately,
they lost a great game,
great fucking game against Georgia.
And uh,
took,
by the way,
who the fuck did Georgia piss off with this September schedule?
Jesus Christ,
Clemson,
Lsu.
And there was somebody else highly ranked that they played.
I forget who.
Um,
but anyways,
in the middle of the game,
like both coaches when they're talking dictate covenant,
that mouse,
the covering their lips as they're talking,
like,
like they were in casino and the announcers even go,
well they must have got word is something going on?
This is everybody fucking does it.
Some fucking reading when,
oh,
Seattle fans was giving me Shit I was talking about,
you know,
cause I made fun of the team was sitting there talking about,
Bella check being a cheater.
It's like,
dude,
did you see what fucking Pete Carroll did down at USC?
What the fuck he was doing?
I don't give him grief about it because everybody was doing it.
But I mean,
come on right as the diggy a team was right as that was coming down,
he fucking slips out of town,
left all those kids high and dry with their scholarships and some no name coach
who I think just got fired.
Um,
how psyched to the Tennessee fans watching the fact that it didn't work out out
there?
That's another shout out to Knoxville.
Jesus,
I'm going to go there one day and they're going to give me the key to this city
and wonder what it looks like.
You know,
am I going to do a redneck joke here?
I don't have one.
Let's plow ahead here.
Everybody.
Um,
so by the way,
so I didn't watch much football because a verse he kept telling me how amazing
the Lawrence Taylor,
uh,
documentary was and uh,
directed by the one and only Pete Radevich shoots the guy who got me on inside
the NFL.
So congratulations to him because I've heard nothing but rave reviews.
And I sat down and watched it and it was fucking,
it was awesome.
It was really awesome.
And you know what,
I don't know if it was the way it was edited,
but there was a lot of shit that the media was doing to lt when he was,
uh,
under the influence that was bugging you don't really bothers me,
is when somebody famous gets arrested and then the cops have to have a press
conference.
Why do they have to have a press conference?
Why do they have to come out?
They would like 20 microphones and everybody taking pictures in the stupid
police chief comes out at approximately,
yeah.
Blend 28.
You Morty.
We lasted a Blab is Tracy and outside of a,
a symphony hall with what we believe was allegedly,
uh,
crack cocaine.
Um,
why can't they just arrest him?
Why do they,
why do they have to have a fucking press conference?
Why do they got to go out there and whore themselves out?
Go into hair and makeup,
get some power to put it on their face,
right?
Slicked back the cop hair and walk out the plan to be fat.
Give hits 28 shut the fuck up.
You know,
and then all the media has to sit there while lt was going through.
His Shit is sitting there acting like this,
shaking their head when they're totally exploiting the guy for ratings that
granted lt put himself out there like that to have it done.
But,
um,
I don't know.
When I have to tell you something in the documentary,
there's something that lts first wife does.
That is one of the things that I find most terrifying about,
uh,
women.
And,
uh,
okay.
I don't want to ruin it for you,
but she says,
lt cries at his daughter's wedding and she comments on his crying and then they
cut to the funeral and she reaches over and puts his,
her hand on his forearm to comfort him after what she had just said is one of
those fucking things that sends chills down my spine.
But definitely check it out.
It's a,
it's fucking amazing.
And um,
if anybody knows just one of the cigars that Lt Smoking,
he looks like he smokes the greatest cigars of all to,
they have two bands on them.
Alright.
So on to me in my ignorance,
that's like the greatest cigar ever.
It's so good.
It had to have a second band on it.
MMM.
I Dunno.
That's what I got.
I,
that's all I got out of it.
That if I ever become a parent,
I gotta be there for my kids.
And secondly,
I got to figure out where lts getting a cigars.
But definitely check that out if you get a chance.
And congratulations once again to Pete rat of it's for doing an unbelievable
job.
That's one of those ones that immediately after I watched it,
when I hit stop and it said if I wanted to erase it or not,
I hit save.
And you know,
you have that save indefinitely.
That's one of those ones I'm going to keep going back to because it was a,
it was tremendous.
All right,
where are we?
Are we going to get into the letters at this point?
And we at that time,
34 minutes then,
hey,
how come you can't protest without getting teargassed shot at?
Yeah.
All around the world.
Get Out.
They act like you,
you know,
we want to hear from our people and you go out there,
he just sitting out.
All you do with it,
you got signs in your chanting and then the cops come down there and they start
pushing people around and they throw fucking tear guests.
I don't understand why.
Why can't you do that?
Why aren't you allowed to protest?
Look,
I understand if you go down there and you start breaking windows and that type
of shit.
Um,
but I,
I actually believe,
and I know you guys are going to think that I'm paranoid,
if I was in power,
I would just say,
hey,
how old your son is.
Set them out there and have him throw a through the window so we can look
justified when we get rid of these fucking people out here.
MMM.
Adam,
sorry,
I'm going back down the fucking rat hole again.
Somebody sent me a great rant that this guy went on on a news program and he was
talking about the bankers.
Uh,
cause I can't even watch the news right now with our government might shut down
in a couple of days with this guy was basically going off saying all that
bankers shit that I was trying to say a few years ago when I started watching
those videos and everybody was saying,
Oh yeah,
these are fucking fat guys living in their mother's basements who a,
they don't have any lives.
And you just,
you know,
you're drinking the Koolaid and all this shit that look,
a lot of that stuff.
We never landed on the moon.
I'll give you all that shit.
Okay.
Maybe all of that stuff.
Nine 11 in inside job.
I'm not talking about any of that fucking crap,
but that bankers shit.
I'm telling you.
Okay.
That bankers shit is dead on dead fucking on.
It's not the left.
It's not the right.
It's those cunts right in the middle with money on both sides of the ball.
It's those guys,
and I have to tell you,
dude,
the fact that the president only makes 400 grand a year and that just the way
they frame it,
like,
oh,
he's a public servant.
It booked up.
It's,
it's the biggest crock of shit out there.
The only person who would take that job,
you'd have to be the biggest fucking yes man on the planet just to get there.
Yeah.
Who the fuck would run for a job where it costs 100 million to get it so you can
make 400 grand a year.
Okay.
Yeah.
That isn't a red flag to anybody.
Then you get to go around giving speeches $1 million.
A whack like that isn't yet kickback for fucking pushing through whatever they
wanted.
I just think it's,
it's so beyond corrupt.
MMM.
And I used to think shit,
like I can't believe we're letting these pencil pushing banking pussies push us
around,
but it's not them.
It's the fact that people will do anything for money.
So when you have that kind of money,
you can hire psychos and uh,
you know,
I dunno,
you get that,
you get that Lincoln town car ride the convertible in Dallas.
All right.
I spoke about it vaguely,
but you know what I'm saying.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's move on.
Okay.
Now I mentioned that I was going to go to Naples and I don't think I might as
well have said that I was going to go with,
to Atlantic city.
Okay.
All right.
Or downtown Detroit.
Yeah.
Everybody is shitting all over Naples.
All right.
Here's one that sums it up.
Uh,
everyone says Naples is the worst words used to describe Naples ship.
Trash haul,
smell like smells like wet rats.
Great.
If you're into visiting the worst part of any place.
If you do go to Naples,
only use it as a jumping off point to Capri and Pompei.
Okay?
Yeah,
I mean that's what everybody has been telling.
Everybody is saying,
look,
if you're going to Italy for the first time,
go to Rome.
All right?
You're going there and December.
So we won't be a big time touristy thing,
but there will be tourists.
Use that as a jump off point.
Go to Florence.
I mean,
I heard Venice,
I mean the fucking place is underwater.
I heard that.
You know,
or that that was kind of smelly.
I don't know.
But you know what?
You guys,
you talked me out of Naples.
You talked me out of it.
Now,
watch,
now hear it comes to the other side.
Don't listen to those fucking assholes.
Whatever.
I've gone to Italy.
How could it possibly suck?
Smash.
Cut.
Alright,
refugee.
Here we go.
Ref.
Ah,
the lovely Nia.
Everybody.
Yeah.
Do you know I,
I spilt my juice all over the fucking place.
The green juice to Cleo.
Get off the bed.
Look at her nose.
A fucking dog tried to get out of the Goddamn cage again cause the wind was
blowing,
bumped up,
scratched up.
A frigging knows pimples.
I swear to God,
India.
Once they get their mind on doing something,
they're just going to do it right.
The brutal.
I didn't know you were coming down.
Go Plug in another microphone.
Let's do the,
uh,
let's do the thing here.
All right.
Do you have the ability to,
uh,
do you have the ability to listen while a while?
I mean,
why you plugged that thing in?
Yes.
All right.
All women think that they can multitask.
It's the funniest fucking thing ever.
I can,
you can,
you can't knit.
Well,
look,
everybody could do two things at once.
You can't fucking Italian play drums.
I can do four things at once.
What are you doing?
That's the wrong one.
Okay.
We'll just continue on.
Huh?
Listen,
scientific studies have shown that people studies have showed one of my favorite
quotes of all time.
I actually saw this on TV that that basically,
if you do two things at once,
they both suffer because you don't have a hundred percent focus.
You know what I mean?
Does that make sense to you?
Yes,
it does.
Okay.
Am I on?
Yeah,
you are right.
All right.
Here we go.
Hey Bill,
this is a refugee.
Hey.
Hey Bill.
I got to know you when I was a refugee in Turkey.
I escaped from prison.
What's,
yeah,
I dunno.
I listen everybody.
Everybody's got the Internet,
man.
You're the number one podcast for refugees,
refugees in Turkey.
Yeah.
This sounds like the beginning of a movie.
I don't know if I'm going to believe this.
Suddenly.
Let's,
let's,
let's see if this is true.
I got to know you when I was a refugee in Turkey.
I escape from a prison sentence for my political activities in the university in
Iran.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
somebody's got to get this guy in touch with Ben Affleck.
Sounds like a movie and he can play him.
Yeah,
I'm telling,
Hey,
I'm Tony Shay then.
No shame.
Hi,
I'm Tony Mendez.
Fucking hilarious.
And then when you saw the real Tony Mendez and he looked like Freddy fender,
that was one of the funniest.
No,
I mean,
I liked,
I liked Argo.
Argo was great,
but the end of that movie,
no shade,
been athletic,
but the whole Dahl movies going,
I'm Tony Mendez,
are you?
If anything would give that guy away would be his last fucking name.
Listen man,
you need to go get more of a 10 a fucking mustache looked at each other when we
said,
when he said that,
like wonders.
No,
I was actually sitting there and the movie go,
wait a minute,
is that Italian?
Maybe he's Mondays.
Mondays.
Hey,
no.
And I'm like,
no,
I done.
I go,
hey,
before that makes it Italian.
Um Oh.
Then the end,
when they sh everybody looked like the person,
but then when they showed Ben Affleck and then they cut the Tony Mendez,
it was this fucking guy.
It was really far away.
It was profile and it was completely shadow.
Yeah.
Everybody else was a close up.
It was this,
it was a full body shot with another white guy in there that he was shaking
hands with it.
You're like,
well,
maybe bends playing in the white guy.
Oh my God.
He's Tony Mendez.
What right there.
Just shows you what an incredible actor he is.
Um,
he played Tony Mendez.
Alright.
Hi Bill.
That was a refugee when I was in Turkey.
I escape from a prison sentence for my political activities in the university
and I ran since I was a kid.
I always loved comedy.
Is this fucking great?
This is why I love,
I love this shit.
Look at this,
this,
this is Billy red face coming out.
Iran.
There were only two funny magazines and I ran and I had all their issues since
the beginning.
Yeah.
This is how lucky we are.
Well,
okay.
Yeah.
They had mad magazine.
I ran in national Lampoon's.
Don't make fun of the ayatollah.
Um,
I didn't know standup comedy existed until I was 25.
Unreal being funny.
It wasn't a good thing.
Uh,
in Turkey I had 30 months.
I guess he had a sentence and I watched everything from prior and Cosby and
Carlin to Hicks to Chapelle.
He was in prison and was able to get to the Internet to watch all these like,
ah,
I don't,
yeah,
I guess so.
What do people make hang gliders in prison or the dental floss and bed sheets.
They can't get the fucking Internet,
uh,
prison.
So No,
you can't get the Internet listen,
which I was actually watching in Iran and I saw you there,
uh,
the first time as well as a detective.
She puts her tits in my hand.
God,
that was funny.
Louis C,
k,
Patrice,
Sam Kennison and you and everything in between.
I have listened to you guys.
This is fucking great.
If this is true,
I have listened to you guys just talking about comedians on radios or podcasts
and I looked them up.
I saw every episode of tough crowd out of all the Comedians I've seen,
you're in my top five.
Ah,
look at this.
You prior Cosby.
Louis Ck is partial.
The gingers and Dave Chapelle.
That's what he likes.
He likes black guys and judges.
I liked this guy.
I started and Jesus,
we'll try to keep it on this side of the road.
Okay.
I started writing and Turkey,
uh,
my friend told me my trend Fran told me to.
I did and it was well received.
I started writing in English and I'm building courage to reform.
This is fucking great.
Uh,
I just want to tell you how much I appreciate those nights when I was sitting
alone in Turkey and I didn't speak its language and I would watch one of your
standups and forget everything and laugh and laugh.
I found out today that that you are in Toronto.
I've been here four months now.
I'll try to find tickets.
How did I miss this email?
If the show hasn't finished yet,
I will see you live,
sir.
I promise.
Thanks again bill and say hi to your near.
That's great.
Well I'm going to tour.
Yeah,
I'm going to tour a Canada
in March.
I'll come through all of these.
What if this is all just a big scam to get him to somehow,
I don't know.
Throw a pie in my face and do something to me.
Come up with that water that squirts in your face.
Where in Canada are you going in March?
Um,
I dunno.
I'm going to go to all the hockey cities and I'll,
maybe I'll add a couple others.
Yeah.
Why don't you just get down to it where you want to go cause you think you
exactly and you think I don't know what you're doing.
That's why you see what just happened there.
This is like two fighters that know each other at this point.
I know what you do and you know what I do.
The second you said the second you said,
why are you going to Canada?
I'm like,
well
where are you going to Canada?
I knew misinterpret everything as some sort of like he's doing right now.
She's filibustering filibustering you know the old kick in the balls and that's
not what this is as asking where you're going in Canada.
If you are going,
why are you smiling at me?
I would want to go to that but I was going to get to it.
You're done.
See you just let it lay it on the ropes.
All right,
so the second you said,
when are you going to Canada?
I knew were in a where you go in and Canada.
I knew,
I'm like she loves Montreal.
She wants to go.
So what I did to slip that punch is I said I'm going to all the hockey cities
cause I know you don't watch sports.
So then you got to be,
so then you had to show your hand.
I called your bluff and you're like,
ah yeah there you go to Montreal.
If you know that,
then just say,
oh I'm I,
I'm am going to Montreal or I am not,
you're doing this.
I Dunno cause he cause it cause it cause it's,
what am I,
I'm going there to work unpacking my hard hat and my mic.
Stand hard.
Yeah.
You don't think it's worth to you of course I think is you don't respect me.
You don't respect what I do.
Just say no.
Jesus.
Oh,
you know what?
Somebody sent a great fucking video this week.
Uh,
some God damn movie with this guy.
He just said,
this is some scene.
He just says,
oh Jesus,
like 15 times in a row.
I got to show you this where it is,
where it is,
what it is,
motherfucker.
All right,
here it is.
Listen to this guy.
Oh Jesus.
Where is that from?
Dylan Moran.
Okay.
I got to tell you.
Yeah,
and my agent's going to get an ear load of shit that I didn't read for that
part.
I would have killed that.
Oh Gee,
thank you.
That's great.
That's great though.
That's how fucking Gigi
he was good,
but he was doing something weird with this voice.
Alright.
Dui.
Uh Oh wait,
I got,
I got to read the other,
uh,
the advertisers here.
All right.
Bear with me here.
Bear with me.
Uh,
okay.
He voice.
All right everybody,
if you're an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're in a high rise window view,
fancy pants office or do you want them to know that you're just sitting there in
your underwear?
Uh,
with the voice,
you can create the appearance of an entire building.
Sales,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it.
They'll think you got it.
Give your customers the royal treatment with he voice.
He voice will forward your business calls.
Do your home mobile or any number you choose.
Whenever,
wherever you are,
he voice will find you.
I know I always,
my brain goes too far ahead in the sentence because you can't do two things at
once,
which is what?
Reading and doing it out loud.
No,
I,
I can't,
I can't do two things at once.
I can't multitask.
Something suffers and neither can you.
Yes,
I can.
Are you done?
Like what?
No,
I'm not.
Oh,
all right.
Well let's stop.
Heckling me.
Don't have time to take a call.
It's routed to your voicemail and you can read it at your convenience as an
email.
A voice not only gives you the edge over your comp competitors,
it takes the edge away from the big companies.
What they have over you right now.
That's the biggest point right there.
Okay.
You get to act like a big shot and now you can try it.
He voice for free for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] dot com or go just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot
com and click on the voice banner.
All right,
last but certainly not least,
uh,
legal zoom.
You know,
a lot of pride comes along with starting your dream business.
But think about the stress you'll feel if you don't take the right steps to
legally protect your business and personal assets from the beginning.
Why?
Because people are sue happy.
So you know what?
That's why I recommend legal zoom.com during the past 12 years,
over a million business owners have trusted legal zone to help start their own
businesses.
Legal Zoom will save you a lot of time and a pile of money on startup costs.
Plus they'll provide solutions to help you run a successful legal zoom can
provide self health services at your specific directions or correct you or
connect you with an attorney,
but they are not a law firm.
Just go to legal zoom.com today to see what's right for you.
Form an LLC,
get a Dba,
incorporate or form a nonprofit all starting at just $99.
Plus you'll save even more when you enter burr and the referral box at checkout.
That's legal.
zoom.com Promo Code.
[inaudible] one more time.
Legal zoom.com.
Promo code birth.
All right.
That wasn't bad.
Only screwed it up once.
Um,
I know I'm the worst story.
Dui.
Hey bill a Billy,
um,
want to start out by saying when he loved stand up.
All right.
I'm 23 year old guy from Houston and on September 22nd,
I was arrested for the first time for a Dwi.
It's funny,
his Dui driving under influence driving while intoxicated in the thing.
All right.
It is,
it's just,
it's called a d.
We do dude.
He got a fucking day.
Wait.
Um,
I took my eyes off the road and rear ended two vehicles at a stoplight.
Oops.
Chayse it,
he split the difference.
We'll either he hit one and it smashed into the other or they were both side by
side.
Maybe he was so drunk he thought he could fit between the two of us.
He said no one was seriously injured,
but the rec brought an ambulance and several squad cars to the scene.
They arrested me and I blew.
So needless to say,
I'm in a pickle.
The lawyer I have,
however,
is good friends with the judge and the court.
He asked for the state's evidence against me and there's a chance we can beat
it.
In the meantime,
the court has me blowing into a breath alcohol device deal type of thing with
the,
with cameras to ensure I'm not drinking and also a piss test.
Every court date,
uh,
this is fine with me because jail sucked.
Court sucks.
And cops in the government workers are extremely rude.
Edge Jesus to was driving drunk.
Yeah,
somebody and their la La la.
Let's see what he says.
Because of all of this and being out on bond,
I'm having to keep my nose extra clean,
have to lay really low and just exist.
It's a bummer and also hard not to think about drinking.
Also,
I got to move out of my folk's house by November 1st they're not kicking me out
or anything.
They're being very supportive.
It's just a date I set for myself before any of this happened.
The fees and the lawyers are going to give me some financial woes and it will be
tough.
Any advice you can give me a will be much appreciated.
Thanks bill.
Well,
I mean,
you should be happy you didn't fucking kill somebody and you know,
if you weren't driving under the influence,
she wouldn't have to run into all these root government workers.
So I would advice that you're looking for here.
You want somehow like hang in there buddy.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I would not have your Goddamn parent's house and lose.
Sorry.
I got no sympathy.
All right.
Nia,
bringing the hammer down.
Uh,
jail sucks.
Oh,
does it?
All right.
Well,
it's hard for me to come down on this guy because,
uh,
all the Shit I've done and I've also,
you know,
fucking,
I got arrested of that shit a long time ago.
I just,
you know what I did?
I took my medicine and you know what?
I remember when I went in and I was finally getting my license back.
The state trooper went to hand it to me and right as I went to gravity,
pulls it back really quick.
He goes,
wait a minute,
was it 90 days or 45 I only got 45 that's how long ago it was.
And I was like,
who's 45 and then he handed it back to me.
He gave me that last little heart attack thing and I was thinking when I was
younger he was a dick.
He was actually doing me a favor,
let me know like,
you know,
this is how simple it is.
And um,
and it was,
and it was an absolute nightmare even at that,
just having my toe dipped into the legal system.
Did they put you in a,
like a holding cell or whatever you got arrested?
How long you in there for?
I don't remember.
I was just like,
they could lay down.
Where there other people in there?
No.
Oh God,
no,
no.
I was fortunate you got arrested in a small town,
but I mean if I buy a,
have you got arrested like in Boston?
Boston?
Yeah,
I would've gone.
I,
they probably would have put me in county and that would've sucked.
That would have sucked.
Cause then you're in there with everybody that's getting a rain for everything
from eating somebody's head to me drinking and driving and he's thinking if I
look like Ron Howard now I look like Ron Howard,
the director now.
But back then I look like Ron Howard living at home with Mr and Mrs. Cunningham.
So that would have been a,
you are opie when you were little then you Richie,
Richie now Ron Howard.
Oscar winning director.
Yeah.
That's a cruel joke.
Speaking of which we got to see Sandy's movie.
Sandy.
Sandra Bullock.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sandy.
I lives next door.
No,
that one looks good.
And so does the,
uh,
the Ron Howard one,
um,
was I gonna say,
uh,
yeah.
So do you know what you did it and um,
look,
it was actually a great thing when I get,
when I got arrested and I had to go through drunk school and all that,
and the mothers against drunk drinking and driving and all this information and
all this stuff that they show you.
And I had to do community service.
I,
they did it at this hospital and I was wheeling all these people down to
physical therapy and uh,
some were born that way.
One got hit by a drunk driver.
So I mean it definitely,
uh,
it hit home and I was a knucklehead,
like this guy kind of feeling sorry for myself rather than thinking about what
could have happened and how dude,
listen,
this is my thing.
You got off easy,
you really got off easy and uh,
having to stay sober is actually a great fucking thing.
It's a great thing.
And um,
to kind of,
you know,
take your foot off the gas pedal there and kind of regroup as far as like when
you can move out.
It all depends on what this whole thing's going to cost you.
But uh,
this all happened because of your actions and you are guilty.
You blew in the thing and you were drunk,
so you got to take your fucking medicine.
When are you going to do so I would,
I would just take it on the chin,
be a fucking man.
And if that makes you have to move out December 1st or January 1st then that's
what you have to do.
And uh,
it's a great way to,
cause it seems to me like you like to party quite a bit,
that just staying sober for a few days.
If it's bugging you like that,
that should kind of tell you something.
Kind of like me with the cigars now you know where I all of a sudden want one
every night.
What did he say about having in judge lawyer?
What did he say?
That he could possibly get out of it and you could fight it and get out of it.
So he's got all these people sort of cushioning him along the way.
Like,
oh my parents aren't kicking me out of there being very supportive and he's got
this person that could possibly get him out because they have an animal.
So everybody's being nice to you,
which is why you then look at the government going,
these guys are being rude to me and he's a kid.
All right,
these guys,
they spoiled Brat is what he is.
Hey,
well look,
nobody,
nobody can hear your point when you come at somebody like that.
I ain't got no fucking Santa you fucking piece of shit like no one here.
That's,
that's how that's political debate in this country right now.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Should I be wrapping my arms around him like everybody else in his life and
telling him die.
Wrap my arms around them.
Okay,
we'll figure it out.
You don't have to move out just yet.
Don't worry.
We got it in and with this judge.
All right.
That's a decent point.
But was I wrapping my arms around him?
Yeah,
but you're coming at me saying nobody hears you when you come at,
you know like that.
Like I'm somehow later on the podcast and you don't have your up.
You not all defensive.
Maybe you can hear what it is that I'm trying to say to you.
Wow.
That's called maturity.
All right.
Oh,
I won that one.
It was just a battle.
It wasn't a war.
You're look at extra cute today,
by the way.
Right?
You don't even try it.
I'm not.
I'm just saying.
You get a nice smile.
All right,
you guys,
you guys are with,
this is my a game by the way.
Uh,
and vice for an atheist in love with Christian fundamentalists.
Oh,
I love it.
Um,
as an atheist dating a Christian fundamentalist,
Jesus Christ,
you thought opposites attract over here.
Nini,
uh,
complete with the purity ring and anal retentive.
Folks,
how funny is it to have purity,
ring and anal for that quick?
I cannot say it initially.
I cannot say it initially seem promising.
Even can even considered living,
uh,
leaving the worst.
I'm the worst.
I know,
but you know what?
This does,
this gives,
but this gives my listeners hope.
I really hope everybody listens.
Who just thinks if this fucking moron can play the Chicago theater,
I can't fucking do it too.
Um,
as I throw each one of you a kiss,
and it's funny when I was trying to send you that song and I said,
as I blow each one of you,
I was gonna say,
blow each one of you a kiss.
And he pauses as I blow each one of you.
When you looked at me like,
what the fuck are you singing?
This is my kind of email.
All right.
Um,
but this,
this girl is really,
she's really something else.
Uh,
you know,
this is probably the sexist in me that I initially thought that it was a guy
with the purity ring and I as a Christian fundamentalist with the purity ring as
a guy,
for some reason,
I think that that's creepier than a woman.
Actually.
She has a purity ring.
Like I think that that's not as creepy.
She has.
Why?
Because as a guy,
he,
you know,
when you fall in love with a woman,
you want one that's been just on the least.
And that's really what it comes down to.
I don't want somebody else's fuck sweat on a checks chest cavity,
eh,
Whoa,
whoa.
You know,
I'm just not,
yeah,
we're very visual animals.
Okay.
There goes the EA game right out the fucking window.
All right?
But this girl is really something else short of sex.
She pushes boundaries.
She demands that she pay for half of our dates,
works her ass off to,
and a year of knowing her,
she has never freaked out.
And the crazy thing,
I can basically go mia for two weeks and it's like nothing happened.
Everything just continues because she's banging somebody else.
I am actually thinking long term at this point,
not marriage.
I'm 21,
God dammit.
And I wonder if this is,
if it's,
if this is worth dealing with the drawbacks of religious pressure pressure's and
no sex for me,
the latter is a pain because I actually cannot masturbate,
just doesn't do it for me,
which was,
so what are you doing during those two weeks when you disappear?
You're going to fucking,
he's going to fuck town there.
Uh,
I cannot promise I will take your advice,
but I will give it some weight.
Well then go fuck yourself.
Go.
Fuck.
I'm gonna sit there wasting my time.
Can we read the next question?
Moving on.
Um,
from a lady,
um,
dear Billy fuckface wow.
Ah,
that's funny.
The gate a longtime listener and fan and incidentally a woman.
So go figure that shit up.
Anyways,
I could use some advice.
I'm getting married this November.
Yes.
I signed up to give away half of my shit.
And this is well only if you're making more than he is.
Um,
other than that,
you signed up for a nice living room set.
Maybe a four bedroom colonial.
My husband's such a jerk.
Oh my God.
At the sprinklers going off again.
Um,
and this is bringing up a lot of family drama.
My paternal grandmother hates my mother.
My grandmother never felt like my mother was good enough for my father.
Oh,
Jesus.
And My mother.
Oh,
as my mother and I am very close.
My grandmother has hated me since birth and has always told me how ugly and
stupid I am.
What is this precious?
Um,
needless to say,
oh,
I do not speak with her and haven't done so in years after she made some racist
comments regarding my future husband as he is Mexican,
the problem comes in when my dad insists that she comes to the wedding,
I have no problem telling my dad to go fuck off.
I do not trust him.
And we do not get along.
Uh,
this screams a lope.
She should be asking me these question.
Um,
my mother and I,
my mother and I are very close and he is using that against me.
I'm saying,
if I don't invite his mother,
he will make my mother suffer.
So do I invite this cunt grandmother to potentially be a racist bigot at my
wedding?
Or I tell my dad to fuck off but hurt my mom and the long run.
Um,
I would just elope.
Yup.
And I would have a party in your backyard.
That's what I would do.
Just go and do it and then come back and be like,
yeah,
we got married and yeah,
the party.
Because I think there's so much resentment and anger and that family and so much
lashing out that I think that they need a clean start,
a clean slate.
Just go out and tell the person that you're going to be with.
But what about his side of the family?
If they love her and then they want to be there.
I know,
but it's like,
it's bigger than that though.
You know?
It's right.
So it's gotta be the two of them and then afterwards they have a big party and
that's the thing.
I mean know always gonna be there.
Oh,
Tony Mendez.
Ben Affleck is Tony's,
Tony Mendez,
city hall or whatever,
and just do it that way.
And then you have a big party later on or something like that.
But um,
I mean even if they have a party,
there's still,
maybe it's going to be these issues.
Did she say that her dad is married to her mom or they're divorced?
Sounds like they're divorced.
He's going to make life a living hell for the mom.
And how would he do that?
Exactly?
Well,
maybe.
Yeah,
Yeah.
I mean who does that to somebody they love build of asshole.
Your Dad is,
I'm sorry about that.
That really,
you know,
it's,
it's human beings.
I don't understand how you just say,
hey,
say lovey.
I mean,
isn't the point of your stupid podcasts and have an opinion about every goddamn
little thing.
Just want to wave your hand in the air and be like,
human beings.
That's life.
Who are you?
Where did you go?
Because you know why fucking drive.
And I'm texting while driving to go down and get the juice today.
Fucking five minutes later I got the juice,
some drive and some fucking asshole in front of me is gone and slow speed and
I've gone slow speeding up.
I go,
but this fucking assholes texting and then I look at him and I'm like fucking
idiots texting blah blah.
And I was just doing it.
Yeah.
So you're a hypocrite.
Right?
But that doesn't mean you can have an opinion.
But am I unique?
Am I am I am I am I unique cause I'm weak.
You're not weak.
You just know you're not weak.
You just have no patience.
All right?
You can't wait.
So your stop somewhere to do what you gotta do.
Christ it didn't I just say how good you looked like you coming at me like this,
they not know and I understand what this is.
You love me and you're worried I'm going to get hurt.
So that's coming out this way right now.
Okay.
I promise I will try and stop texting.
I'll try and stop yelling.
I'll try and stop being a piece of shit.
I'll try to stop fucking,
I wonder these days in the year I'm going to be that guy.
I'll be that fucking guy.
I want you to be anybody but yourself,
but well then you know what?
You know what?
Yeah.
The thing is is you think that like if I scrape way all this shit,
what do you think is under these cysts?
The guy drinks the Dole second with the cougar in his kitchen.
That's not who's going to be,
I'm going to go back.
I'm going to go with the most interesting man in the world.
I'm just going to end up being fucking eight year old Billy.
Oh boy.
You won't go to the movies tonight.
I like with that.
Why?
I like that Billy.
Now you don't,
what do you mean?
Cause this is the deal.
When I am actually,
when I am on the rare times when I am in a chilled out mood and I am going with
the flow and whatever you want to do,
I'm like,
yeah,
let's do it and I don't question it or anything.
You get a concerned look on your face and you like,
are you okay?
Are you okay?
And then I say what?
I'm,
I'm being the guy you want me to be right now of me.
That's about it.
That's,
that's how rare it is for you to be that person that has nothing.
No,
but then I understand that part.
But then you also said to me one time like,
well,
I don't want you to,
then you get like concerned.
I don't want you to be somebody you're not.
Right.
So when there's,
so when you see chilled out me,
it,
it like you almost talked me out of it and I get it too because the seat shelled
out me is such a fucking shock to you that you want to make,
you want to go fucking,
you know,
put your hand on my forehead to make sure I don't want have a FEMA,
uh,
you know,
appreciate it.
Yeah.
And this,
yeah,
that right there
is why men and women will never get along.
All right,
here's the wrap up.
But right there near,
it's just like,
are you okay?
It doesn't mean you make it feel like I'm fucking weird cause I'm chilled out
and then,
and then you go all in,
you fucking turn it all the way to the other side.
It doesn't mean I know to appreciate it.
Is Everything okay?
But I like it.
What's wrong with you?
You're all over the double line.
Pick a fucking lane.
You pick a lane.
Hey,
hey,
be in the situation.
The lovely knee.
Everybody.
Oh uh,
you did.
We're going to be right back.
Um,
all right,
the wrap up.
I need a Dj for this part.
The wrap up.
Uh,
now that the show was over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu Plus Hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smartphone,
a tablet,
support this podcast.
Get an extended free trial of Hulu plus when he go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] Dot Com and click the Hulu plus banner,
she'll be or click the Hulu plus banner photo is and Click the Hulu plus ban a
fuck I was right there.
Or go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill.
You know what to do.
Um,
hey and uh,
definitely check out that youtube video.
You got to see the oh Jesus one.
Whoever sent that one.
And that was such a great find.
Uh,
Ania,
who did the Patriots have next week?
Who are we playing that team from?
'Em Up there.
They want a few times.
Just,
just pick a name a few times.
Pick,
pick,
pick the name of the team.
You know the,
uh,
the,
the bears,
the bears.
That's not bad.
I don't know.
We're not,
we're not playing that division.
Let me,
let's see.
I'm on a schedule and stats schedule,
season schedule,
Bang.
What do we got here?
Oh,
next week we're playing the Bengals.
Who I heard are under achieving.
That's what I read on the thing.
All right,
well we shall see,
right?
Huh?
Bangled tag Bengal tigers,
which are native to India,
which is in Asia,
which is part of
Asia,
which is part of the world.
What are you talking to me?
Which is a tiny.in
the universe.
You kept going?
Yeah.
You're like India,
Asia,
the world,
the universe.
Yay.
All right.
This is what the Patriots have come up.
These are our next three games,
the bangles,
which I think that's a dangerous game.
All right?
There are a wounded animal.
Those bangles,
nanny,
they're backed into a corner.
Uh,
the saints is going to be a rough one.
And the jets that's at the jets,
it's,
I know they supposed to,
supposed to stink this week,
this,
this week.
This year they're supposed to stink,
but we already beat him.
And it's a division rivalry.
And uh,
they always play as tough.
We had a,
was it 13 to 10?
Says right here.
I'm 2121.
When we played the bills,
those division rivalry games,
I like taking the under.
Um,
so anyways,
I don't even know what the Monday night game is this week,
but,
uh,
I'm gonna try to get caught up on the football and uh,
I'll tell you the Broncos and Seahawks Neenee,
I think they're on a collision course.
What do you say?
Sure.
Absolutely.
So a few.
If a,
if a bronco collide in a seat,
in a Seahawk,
whatever the fuck that is.
I think that it's a sin.
It's a seagull on roids it's a bird cause I,
yeah,
but when you look up to see hockey,
can't find it other than the team.
I just remember being like an eighth or seventh grade and um,
the boys are where those starter jackets and I remember the Seattle Seahawks and
it was like a bird face.
Isn't that there?
Yeah,
that's their logo.
The logo.
Sorry.
Oh there it is.
Is that what the fuck it looks like.
You know why?
Cause they sit,
they spell it one word
but you just write see Hawk and then you just have the image.
Dude.
Is there anything like more evil looking than a bird of prey is saying they
never look like they're in a good mood.
Like poisonous snakes.
They always have like their right,
they're nonexistent.
Eyebrows are always down.
Okay,
there we go.
See that does,
I said hits of anger.
Yeah.
That's what it looked like on this day.
Or you don't.
If you were a bird,
that's the kind of bird you would be attracted to me.
I got to stop dating these birds of prey.
They're such an assholes.
You know it's funny cause I was thinking when you were describing like,
oh,
you'd like a vulture.
I was like,
you're like,
I was thinking that that was,
you know,
you'd like a vulture with that red heads.
You get me.
That's what I'd be picking at a caucus.
No,
you'd be like this.
You'd be like a Seahawk looks.
I wasn't,
I wasn't fishing for a compliment here.
I was just saying no,
no.
The,
these are the guys you dated before you got to me.
I'm not a bird of prey and I'm not a bird of prey knee.
I know how to make a pie.
Yes you did.
Yes,
I did have a very,
you know what I'm like,
yes.
I'm a
Billy the banker.
I'm a Blue Edison.
I'm a dove pasty white.
Now you're a woodpecker.
Just cause I'm like,
go fuck yourself.
That's actually the bat.
That's probably the best one.
All right,
so you got the last one in.
There you go.
Yay.
All right.
This week I'm going to be in El Paso.
This whole run.
I'm going to be with a rose bowl king Rosebowl tailgate legend Joe Bart.
Nick.
We're going to be an El Paso on Wednesday.
Then we're going to San Jose on Thursday,
and then I'm going to fucking Seattle.
Um,
we'll see how loud they are in Seattle.
Then I'm gone on Friday,
and then I go to a Phoenix and a on Saturday,
and that's it.
And that's,
that's,
that's fucking it.
That's what I'm going to be.
Right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you so much for listening.
Thanks for all the great emails and the youtube videos and all the people around
the world who've been listening.
Uh,
I really appreciate it.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.